[Applause]
is this
like they are there were very excited is
this like when you go to Target does
this just happen when you enter what's
Target what I love Target kidding you go
in for one thing and leave with 50 that
you don't need yes always yes um your
birthday is tomorrow right so what do
you do what do you do for your birthday
do you go big or do you chill I'm I'm
I'm going to be playing a show oh you go
big in New York yeah I played a show my
last birthday yeah it's so fun to do
that is it like a big release thing um
it's just the way the schedule worked
out but I don't know I'm I'm not like
huge on my birthdays and and to be
honest I actually couldn't think of
anything more fun to do than to share
you know my music and with my fans and
and and your band your band is
incredible like I've seen you I've seen
you a few times live and you're you're
incredible it's an incredibly physical
show I love how much you incorporate
your band like you really highlight them
singers not everybody and it's a it's a
really cool thing to go you get to see
him live but then also he showcases
these incredible musicians you share
stage with yeah they're so good it's um
they're like family to me now I mean
we've we've toured for for a long time
together a lot of them yeah and um music
to me one of the most valuable things
that you can experience in music is
collaboration yeah and sharing the stage
with such amazing musicians it would be
a travesty to not showcase them yeah no
I agree I feel the same way about my
crew they're they're so gifted and I
don't know that walk out music got me
yes so you you recently performed in
your hometown so like when you do a show
because you've had so many hits there's
so many things people want to hear you
saying but is there one that you still
love doing like is there a favorite song
of yours uh well in reference to to
Memphis playing the show there it that
was the first time time we played uh
selfish um so that made you were there
oh my
gosh
wow oh my gosh look yeah I I when I
found out you were performing I
literally booked the flight booked
hotels not knowing I was getting in and
that's why we have and I
literally I live in Jersey did you have
did you have a good time I amazing time
I still have the bracelet on I can't
take myself to I found out I was coming
here yest did you know he was going to
drop the new single yes I mean all the
subliminal messaging on your you know
your Tik Tok we you know we try to
figure it out I like it I like it we're
like CIA agents but yes I it was
unbelievable and I can't wait to well as
we say in Memphis thanks for coming
thanks for coming unbelievable I'll do
it come on back anytime you won't well
so you did the new song There selfish
but what's like one of your favorite
like like I always still love doing
independent yeah like I I always love
doing lovep it's my first single and I
don't know why I love it live I love it
live what is do you have a favorite I
mean rock your body's fun still rock
your body mirrors mirrors is still fun
to sing although sometimes I'm like why
did I write this in this key it's very
high that's what I say a lot um yeah
yeah cuz why I don't go on stage until
like 900
p.m. yes you're isn't there yet it's not
there yet
what do you this is a real question
great impersonation by the
way I was trying to do my falsetto and
my head voice and I was like don't suck
um I enjoyed it so thank you um what do
you have left to conquer because we have
worked together in the studio and by the
way I think because of your background
and how much you are so good at Harmony
and I loved how you recorded me and I
loved all your ideas and the freedom you
give singers you're really great saying
that because I'm here no I know I've
have said that this when you're not I
was like he actually makes for a great
producer cuz I don't find that I'm good
at producing like that but I love
singing but you you produce you write
songs you act you you do all the things
is there anything left you've had such
an illustrious career like is there
anything left that you want to do that
you haven't done yet um well first of
all that was very kind um it was honest
I
I growing up in in the industry and
getting access to so much in the studio
yeah I just became like a student R like
I just loved being in there and I loved
the the creative process and and you
know and and also as it pertains to
harmonies um I spent some time with four
other guys doing a lot of harmonies who
who are you speaking
of uh by the way y'all broke the
internet when y'all came back for the
song yeah that was that was fun that was
fun it was kind of crazy like there's so
much that just picks up right where it
left off as far as the chemistry um but
uh
yeah yes just saying I don't normally I
don't want people to think can what is
that can you see that picture again I
don't I I feel like I have to disclaimer
like I was having a really bad allergy
day and that's why I was wearing the
sunglasses I don't want no um but um
yeah we we we've been in the studio so
there may be a little okay that's I was
going to ask yeah it's
exciting it's exciting his new album is
called Everything I
thought it's out now I've been to your
performances I was talking about earlier
and and you're it's a very physical show
it is you have to be exhausted at the
end of it I am yeah I am not that kind
of exhausted after my show I'm like walk
to the right walk to the left I'll tell
you though like I I actually when I come
off stage I'm so amped from that like I
have trouble going to sleep me too you
know yeah that's why I like to go on
earlier I can finally you might be on to
something we should yeah I'm going to
I'm I'm GNA think about this I'm just
saying um so your new album so it's
called Everything I thought it was
that's the title so what what did you
think it
was uh yeah uh I'm still trying to
figure that out yeah um it's interesting
I I never sort of with song titles when
I'm writing a song I never I never know
what the song title is sort of until I
fin fin the song and and and that sort
of applies with with with albums I would
I would play I I started working on this
album over the the pandemic and I ended
up with about I don't know close to 100
songs yeah and narrowed them down to 18
which is hard and and which was which
was hard to do but when I started
piecing the album together and picking
my favorites I would play it for people
close to me and and they would say oh
this this sounds like this sounds like
every part of you of every album mixed
into oh that's cool anation of all it
yeah yeah and and having this moment in
my life and and sort of looking back
on everything that it's been and and I
think you know sort of accepting all of
it and being excited about all of it
learning from all of it applying that to
moving forward in your life um good and
the bad yeah yeah the good the bad the
fast the slow I think you get to this
point where you sort
of uh you arrive at peace with all of
that and there's also a couple of songs
um that book in the the the album that
are a little more
introspective and the last line of the
first song on the album you know I say
I'm everything I thought I I'm
everything you thought I was I'm
everything I thought I was it was
everything I thought it was oh I like
and and um you know it's just about
arriving at this place right now in my
life as an artist as a a husband as a
father as a human and um I'm just really
excited about what the future holds I
think that's the cool thing about being
an artist in whatever form you are an
artist it's such a blessing to have that
outlet first of all for the therapy
reasons alone for sure yeah but then
also it's ever changing like we don't
it's not a monotonous job you don't come
in you know what I'm saying every
album's different every part chapter of
your life is different it inspires
something different I think that's rad
we're very lucky we are yeah I agree um
well Justin teased uh the album as eii
tiw on Instagram and people started
guessing what it meant I was going to go
with EI
EO well this is this is pretty great
someone said it stands for every time I
Twerk I win which kind of kind of you do
I mean if you're able to twerk I it's a
good day um everyone in Texas is winning
that's my personal favorite for obvious
reasons yeah um everyone is totally into
werewolves yeah I'm into werewolves
that's a choice I'm into Wolverine I'm
into that I mean every time every time I
Twerk I win I mean that's pretty great
um I also do want to explain the trailer
though because it's benis Del Toro right
that's the voice right the narrator
what's what here let's play it real
quick what do we have here oh that's a
nice car wait it's a
model did that say
JT okay that Sunset is definitely not
real oh there's
Justin why would he turn
around what the is he staring
[Music]
at what what's going on
there is it going to unfold what's
happening there was that not the
greatest voice yes of all time the
greatest last line he is he is just one
of my favorite people I had the the
fortune of the last film that I did
called reptile we work together and um
he's just he's just the best yeah the
fact that he said yes he's like yeah I
got this yeah it it I I literally I I
called him we had the same manager and
we became friends a while ago and and
then we ended up working together and um
I just we were we had shot the footage
and we were thinking about who would be
the voice and I was like oh benio and so
he was he I I we called him and he's so
funny he's like I only do push-ups for
you bro push-ups for you yeah I do
push-ups for no one yeah um but he he's
the best and and such a good friend and
I was yeah I can't wait to see he's like
my favorite part of the whole process
right now I love it well I mentioned the
single the first single is selfish so
Justin sings If I get jealous I can't
help it I want every bit of you I guess
I'm self selfish it's bad for my mental
but I can't fight it that's a very sexy
lyric man yeah you want every
bit all of it yeah all of it all of it
all of it yeah I love that what is what
did you okay okay
okay you're you're G have to buy the
album to figure out all the all the
meanings but I no I love a lyric that
kind of leaves it open too like it's you
know what I'm saying I think that's very
it's enticing um I had gone to one of my
friends who's also my music director on
on tour Adam Blackstone who is fantastic
yes and uh he he was doing these Jazz
nights at at a at a small spot in LA and
he asked me to come and I did a cover of
a
cover uh which is Donnie Hathaway's
version of John Lennon's jealous guy and
I came back to the studio after that and
there was something in the air about
just the lyrical content of that and and
sort of what John linen wrote about
being about just humbling himself to the
fact that he has those types of emotions
yeah and um I just felt really inspired
by by sort of that that sentiment yeah I
love the song it's also like one of
those things that even though it's a
natural emotion um not you know not
feeling Shame about having natural
emotions and talking about that with
your significant other yeah it which is
not not in the South especially for boys
so that's really cool that you're open
about that that's awesome yeah it's not
and and all feelings are valid they are
and and I think that's the sexiest thing
ever is when you have that communication
with your partner and you can talk about
any and everything yeah oh absolutely
one day let's do another short
commercial break Justin's new album is
called Everything I thought it
was the first single is called Selfish
Che
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y have a great night I'm
going
home